one of the most annoying things of
running a business is holding people
accountable I mean just the word
accountability by itself is boring but
here's what I've learned I've learned
most of the time entrepreneurs who want
to make it and once you build a big
business they only their selective
hearing the only one to hear the
exciting things you know what is it
going to be when I'm a millionaire what
is going to be when I'm driving a nice
car and I have a Ferrari or a Porsche -
big house all this stuff and people
now-famous up forget about that the
reality it is behind closed doors what
are the boring things I'm supposed to do
to give me even a chance at scaling my
business to this level and
accountability is one of those them so
let's talk about accountability I'm
gonna talk about nine effective ways to
holding your team accountable in this
video well prior to getting into it I
want to explain to you why the
importance of this so here's here's what
you got to keep in mind one we hate it
when someone holds us accountable no one
likes it we don't like you when our
parents were less accountable we don't
like you when our spouse holds us
accountable we don't like it when our
sibling holds us accountable we don't
like when our boss holds us accountable
we don't like when our football coach
anybody we just don't like to be held
accountable because there's a
possibility of a letdown and we didn't
do something as effective as we should
have been but you know what's even more
annoying then being held accountable
this is what I've learned most people
don't like to hold other people
accountable most people don't like to
other people accountable most people are
afraid of hold on other people
accountable why is that because we don't
like to show someone that they're not
efficient enough we don't like to show
someone that they didn't hit their
commitment because we generally want
people to like us and if I hold this
person accountable we get off the call
nothing about it is exciting so we get
off the call you know I can't believe it
I just I don't want that friction with
the other person so I'm not very good at
holding people accountable it's not that
you're not very good at holding people
accountable it's that you don't like to
hold people accountable because you get
the feeling that you're not having that
person like you at that time and you got
to grow up and become a big boy and a
big girl to run a big business if you
don't do that you will go out of
business very quickly or stay small
forever and never develop row leaders
see I have two kids and with my boys
when I think about my father raising me
my father was very good at teaching me
certain things Pat don't be afraid of
this you can't do this you got to do
this you got to do that my boys the
other day one of them was wrestling with
me and then he goes to mom and mom is
just laying there and he's just running
on a post monster very bad and I pulled
them aside I said come here right now
come here right now Tico comes aside I
said look at me look at me my's look at
me my eyes I said you don't ever ever
pull your mother's hair ever you don't
touch your mother you don't pull her
hair you don't touch a woman ever you
don't ever lay a hand on a woman ever
you don't ever do this why was that that
specific because that is a very very
important thing for this kid to learn at
40 years old so he never does that for
so you don't ever do this um the only
person that gets to call your mother
says the daddy and every time I've done
that we've had a baby we got a third one
other way now that's a whole different
story I don't wanna get into that that's
not the purpose of this video so
accountability is that I don't want to
have that conversation with my son I'd
rather wrestle with the god right I
haven't hit me in the face and we
wrestle he pulls my ear we're having a
good time and we kissing we're doing
this up it's just running around where
I'd rather do that I don't want to sit
down and tell the kid not to do certain
things but he's depending on me to do a
long term if I truly want to build a
leader if I truly want to build a leader
the only way I want to build a leader is
by putting them on the spotlight to know
that long-term we can end up becoming a
leader when you look at some athletes in
sports that are difficult people to
coach like a DeMarcus Cousins that's got
so much talent but someone needs to get
ahold of this guy and put him in his
place and Sacramento's management team
is not allowing that to take place
that's why that guy is not going to be a
leader until the management team defends
the coaching team but anyways this is
not ESP we're talking business here so
let's get right into it let's get right
into it
point number one of what is an effective
way to holding your people accountable
number one very simple do not be afraid
to hold them accountable and call them
out when they don't keep their word it's
very simple don't be afraid to do that
don't be afraid to say how come you
didn't hit the number that you committed
to why did this not hit it's very simple
why did you not hit this number here
make it very clear that this is not
personal because some
when I'm holding people accountable the
energy enthusiasm needs to go lower you
raise it you're sounding like you're
upset at them so you're almost call
order and you say hey you said last
money we're going to do this much and
you did this any reason why you don't
hit your commitment so when do you think
I can count on you delivering our new
commitments when do you think I can what
do you think we're going to work on this
number being met anything we can do that
because you look me mize and you told me
you're going to do this much we didn't
do that much
when is it we can cannot count on you
deliver them on your numbers and I'm
gonna have a conversation with the MA
and say listen know this as a person
we're good I don't have a problem with
you as a person I have a very big
problem with your performance I think
you can do better but I have a problem
with the fact that you only had 40% of
your commitment that you made why is
that number one confront don't be afraid
to question their answers question their
answers I'll tell you what I mean by
questioning their answers if somebody
for instance if I'm doing a conference
call and I'm holding accountable and
somebody says I says how many phone
calls that you make they'll say I'm
around 200 I say around I said there's
no such thing as around you either made
187 calls or you made 192 calls but
there's no such thing as around how many
people did you talk to last week around
10 people there is no such thing as
around did you talk to five did you talk
to 611 eight what is it specific
so don't let them get away with telling
you around somewhere around I'm not a
founder the ward around around is not
specific I need specific I was having a
meeting last week where we had Maury we
were in Chicago on on set on Friday and
I had a meeting and we were having a
meeting on Friday were Saturday with
some of the leaders and one of the
leaders I was talking to I said so let
me ask you a question why are you doing
this business and he said well I'm doing
this business because I want to become
financially free I said I have a hard
time believing that and he says what do
you mean I said have a very hard time
believing that I said how many hours a
week do you work what time you come to
the office is 8:00 a.m. at the office so
what time do you leave 10:00 p.m. I said
you're at the office 14 hours a day yes
I said okay
I said how good of a closure are you in
the field he said I'm the best in the
office I said you're the best in the
office what percentage of the time do
you close
at attend appointments how many will you
close he says 80% I'll close I said you
should have never told me that he said
why is that I said well because you've
only closed six policies for the entire
year okay and out of six policies you've
closed for the entire year you're an 80%
closer that means you've only ran eight
appointments for the year so in the ten
weeks that we've had this year so far
you ran eight appointments that's less
than one appointment a week Ted how many
points do you run a week he says that's
about right
I said you run one appointment a week it
says yes I said how many phone calls you
make a day says five I said why are you
even doing this business as it's not
fair to your family so you gotta go get
a job you can't be an entrepreneur like
this your wife's counting on you I said
so tell me about a cause you're making
I'm making five tell me about what
you're doing throughout the day are you
checking news Newsweek news feed on
Facebook all that what are you doing and
we went through this I've done this with
numerous people and I said do you really
want to become financially free yes I
said it doesn't sound like it does your
activity sound like you want to be
financially free no why are you being so
is that rich I'm going deep into finding
the reason because if I don't get that
deep you're going to leave and there is
no effectiveness in that meeting you
think you had an effective meeting
because sometimes you know we go and the
message is just about motivation
motivation what no no motivation without
numbers and specific accountability
nothing happens so we went deeper and
deeper and deeper until it was clear and
then they need an instruction of one two
three so if they agree with you and
they're coachable which in this scenario
that was the case then I have to give a
one-two-three here's three things I want
to see happen one you got to figure out
why you're doing this business - you got
to meet with your wife three I need a
message from you for you tell me why
you're doing this business on what's
going to change what you're moving
forward fair enough and then BOOM that's
what I got from them and then that came
back to me I figured it out and then we
move forward with the next step
right so number three now number three
effective way of holding people
accountable make specific statements not
general let me explain what I mean by
specific statements rookie leaders tend
to do a lot of pro but I think you can
do it you know we got to get it together
we're a great team we're going to go
pull this off this is amazing this is
great general general
in general general case specific listen
do you really want to get it going
yes here's what I think you need to do
you need to run a minimum of 20
appointments a week you need to make a
minimum of 200 calls a week you need to
finish a minimum of a book every two
weeks you need to thought that that that
specific specific specific well let's
get specific Bob I'll try to be more
specific can I get your buy-in on this
yes what can I expect from you
boom-boom-boom what's going to change
with you
Bombo most specific statement not
general statements now here's another
one as well
what statements you make that moves
people specific what moves people
deadlines in sports players play because
I have a 24-second shot clock you have
24 seconds to shoot the ball in football
you have 35 seconds to make a play there
is a deadline you have the fourth
quarter six minutes left two-minute
warning there is a deadline if there is
deadlines of sports there's got to be
deadlines in business because there's
definitely deadlines of life 80 to 90 or
some of us 100 years there's a deadline
we're not going to live for a thousand
years there's a deadline we got to go
get a gun we gotta go get it going we
gotta go get it going I'm gonna turn 30
years old so now I'm up to 40 years old
so now I turn 21 years old so what's my
life look like did I think I was gonna
be at this level Authority there's got
to be deadlines so what are you gonna
get this done you got one more week by
Friday I need to so XYZ what can I see
by Friday specific specific deadlines
deadlines deadlines minimize general
statements specific deadlines is I want
to speak with your teammates five give
clear expectation for sorry step number
four is give clear expectation the
clearer you are the more they know how
to rise up to it the general you are I
mean this is a little bit different than
the measuring with the numbers but be
clear in whatever direction you're given
be clear whatever expectation you have
with them general people sit there and
say I want to move but what do you want
me to do here's what I want you to focus
on clear pop up up up up perfect step
number five use measurable figures the
benefits of use and measurable figures
is it avoids conflict because no one can
get upset at their numbers if I sit in
and I tell you you tell me you're going
to do this
but this is how much you did at the end
of the month you said you're gonna make
25 cells where you made six cells what
happened to you that's a very big
difference it's not like you fell short
by 10% on only the 22 cells
you went from 25 to 6 cells how is that
possible that's a were you working what
were you doing so tell me and then
they're gonna explain it to you right
and uh the reason why I like to use
numbers because it is in my opinion I
send a message this morning to some
leaders and this is what I said to them
in the message I said you know there's a
lot of people that want to brag about
how hard they work I've been in this
business long enough and when I would
hear people saying I work so hard I you
know you don't understand I'm working
hard I come to the office early I make
so many calls I'm reading I'm developing
myself how is this business not working
for me here's what I tell us you know
it's the difference between meaning
what's that what you're telling yourself
is that there's a possibility that if
you do everything you can possibly do in
this business you can still fail I don't
subscribe to that mindset what do you
mean see I believe that if you follow a
certain format and you work hard and you
give everything you got in my opinion
100 percent guarantee you're going to
succeed that's my opinion that's my
opinion my opinion is I'm working so
hard and it felt not possible it's
mathematically impossible it is not
possible it is not possible for me to
say I'll take a hundred shots and I make
zero it's not possible I find my
two-year-old cannot I don't have the
strength for it it's not possible for me
to take 100 shots today and only make
nine and next week I take 100 shots and
I only make nine and next week I take
100 shots and I only make nine no
eventually is going to go nine then 11
then 12 then 13 and 17 out of 119 out of
100 then 20 out of 100 I'm gonna get
better as long as I'm making adjustments
I'm gonna get better but when somebody
says I'm working hard but nothing's
closing I don't believe that I don't
believe that how many points you round
last week how many calls did you make
last week how many people did you go and
visit there how many people did you
reach out last week there is no such
thing as hard work without it working
because math doesn't lie
the number four comes after the number
three the number five comes after the
number four the more you're driving with
specific measurable numbers the more
people
can look at that and saying I just can't
hide behind numbers so at the end of the
day reports don't lie numbers don't lie
a leaders bulletin doesn't lie and that
supports how hard you're working or that
says you're just making it up your
biessing everybody
you're not working that hard you keep
telling you're working hard but your
numbers are not reflecting that so
that's why I like numbers because it
never lies to me and typically when it
comes to the area of talking about
numbers I'll come back and I say listen
there's five reasons again if we're
still on the on the point of giving
measurable figures to help avoid
conflict if for me there's five reasons
why somebody doesn't do well in sales
five reasons why somebody doesn't do
well in sales or whatever they're
selling number one it's hard working and
working hard hard enough you're in
running enough appointments to his
competency you don't know the product
very well so you need to take the time
to learn the product three is how to you
don't know how to sell so you may know a
lot about the product or you're not a
good salesman because some people say
well I've been in sales for 20 years
then how come you're not selling
anything because you're not taking the
time to be competent in the product just
because you were good in pharmaceutical
sales doesn't mean going to do get in
real estate just because you were good
and sell real estate that's maybe going
to do get in insurance you need to take
the time and have you become competent
in that product for is your identity you
don't believe you're worth people doing
business with you need to work on your
identity you have limiting beliefs and
then 5 is people skills you're just not
good with people you've got to learn how
to read how to win friends and influence
people got to get better with people you
learn how to become more charismatic
charming your own weight how to look at
people in the eyes how to stand certain
ways how to talk to people in a certain
ways and those are things that can be
work done those are not things that
cannot be worked on nothing about that
has to do with god-given talent all of
that has to do with things that you can
work on and improve sixth way to hold
people accountable consequence is if the
job doesn't get done consequences if the
job doesn't get done what does this mean
does this mean they get fired like oh do
you really sit there and threaten people
if they don't get fired no but this is
how I explain it let me expect how I
explain it I'll sit down and I'll say
this I said let me ask you a question do
you think just because I'm a CEO of this
financial firm and we're worth whatever
we're worth some people say we reward 50
some people say we're worth 100 whatever
people say we're worth do you think me
as the CEO of this company you think
I'll ever get fired and if you know
you're the CEO I said what do you mean
you don't think I'll get fired
how do you think CEOs get fired do you
know who fire CEOs who fire CEOs
customers sales reps employees board
vendors carriers you don't think CEOs
get fired CEOs get fired every single
day I can get fired the consequences of
me as a CEO not being at the top of my
game and being casual and not getting
better and not building relationships
with the vendors carries all that stuff
the consequences of me not making the
environment better for my employees not
making a better for my sales reps not
making a better for my vendors my care
of it you don't think I'll get four I'll
get fired
absolutely I'll get fired so what makes
you think you can't get fired you also
can get fired I never thought about it
that way well listen if your sales
you're not selling your clients gonna
fire you if your sales you don't call
your clients are gonna fire you if
you're a supervisor or your director of
leading 2030 people and you're not in
the office selling yourself and your big
shining you're driving your
mercedes-benz you come to the office at
11 o'clock in the morning or 10 o'clock
in the morning your people gonna fire
you they're gonna go work for somebody
else I've said it over and over again if
you don't take care of your people
somebody else will if you don't take
care of your people somebody else will
so there's consequences if you don't do
this and you explain this and when I
explain this then we have an
understanding then we take the next
steps of what happens if you don't take
your business seriously and then they
understand so what are the consequences
whatever it is you've got to give them
their consequences if this does not
happen here's what could happen fair
enough great next up point number seven
coach them through their challenges so
it's not just about coming and saying
you're not doing this you're not do now
you're not doing this you're not gonna
talk about great without my meeting know
a good leader is gonna say let me give
you some coaching here's what I suggest
in this area do this this this in that
area have you tried doing this this this
I was talking to one of our guys and I
said listen you seem so stiff around
people when you and I are around each
other you're so comfortable why are you
so stiff and uncomfortable well you know
I'm just now I said here's what we need
to do every time we go into elevator or
we go someone would talk to the people
around me just spark a conversation I
said next elevator you're sparking a
conversation okay I can do that start it
next time we'll go you stuck Alma to do
that because its direction being given
so here's what I think here's what I
want to coach you to try this try that
read this watch this video listen to
this podcast
listen to this iTunes but there's got to
be coaching and Direction being given
after you holding people accountable
point number eight the importance of the
role they play on the team Mario and I
were talking to you the more you give me
a very interesting thing Mario said Pat
do you really think my vote counts
you really think my vote counts I said
what do you mean he says you know do
people's vote really count
I said that's very interesting you say
that and let me explain it to in
complete different ways I said do you
think if you weren't doing what you're
doing with the company you think the
company would feel it you think you
doing something important for the
company I think so I said I think so too
then I went through one by one by one
everybody that's here I said do you
think that person's playing in program
yeah how about this person yeah
how about Baba Mahabharata Mohammed yeah
yeah oh yeah so let's take them out do
we feel it yes their vote counts if
their vote counts that means your vote
counts the point I'm trying to make to
you is your position is a very very
important role in the company you ought
to take it very serious because the
company sees effects of you not taking
this thing serious we need you to rise
up and perform at the highest possible
level that I know you can but you've got
to understand you are a very big
important part of this company here once
you explain that and I firmly believe
that then they understand the important
role they play in wearing the jersey
that you represent but they got to know
that and the last point point number
nine is is you got to finish with love
and let me tell you what I mean by love
you know you got to know that you're
dealing with human beings you got to
know that you're dealing with people
these people have emotions these people
have pride they have bragging rights
they want to know that they make a
difference it's important for you to
know what role they're pregnant or in
your company what are their long-term
goals the long-term vision what are some
things they want to help become a
reality in their lives and if you truly
you truly care about that becoming a
reality for them I guarantee your team's
going to feel it and they're not going
to have a problem allowing you to hold
them accountable because you truly want
to help them advance in their own lives
whatever that may be whatever that may
be you see them advancing in their own
lives so when I sit down and I have a
conversation with somebody
and the conversation ends you know it's
RiRi minding them that we're here to
help you and I want to see your dreams
become a reality where you got to step
up your game and I think that's one of
the most important things and
accountability when you see coaches
football players football coaches
basketball coaches and you see some
players that are willing to run through
the wall for certain coach you better
believe John Wooden wasn't just great at
teaching stuff you better believe you
know Pete Carroll isn't just a guy that
knows how to you know call the best
place matter of fact he's not even known
for the best play call but as people
really believe that he loves them his
people really believe that he's a leader
is people really believe when he calls
them out you got to be that type of a
leader when you want to give people to
be held accountable you want to hold
them accountable and don't be afraid
about holding them accountable start
that today figure out an area in your
business they can hold somebody
accountable and try it today start with
your kids start with everybody around
you and you'll see a bigger difference
taking place in your life and you'll
also be recognized as a leader instead
of just somebody that's out there
playing their own role hold them
accountable they'll appreciate so what I
would tell you is this if you watch this
video accountability goes very much with
time wasters Ilia if we can put a link
can we make that thing sound out
allowing your sound come up there you go
so click over here to watch the video
I've been on 16 time wasters of
entrepreneurs because I think time
wasters goes very much with
accountability both of them you'll get a
lot about to help them with
accountability as you're coaching people
as well as yourself with that being said
if you haven't subscribed to this
channel please do so the links should be
on the bottom here and if you haven't
gone to the website Patrick video be
calm see it right here Patrick big David
Beckham click here to go to the website
you'll find a ton of content there as
well thanks for watching take care
you